[Music]
russians are scrambling to get their
fast food fix now that mcdonald's
announced it will temporarily close more
than 800 locations in protest of
russia's invasion of ukraine video
posted to social media this week shows a
long line of cars backed up at a russian
mcdonald's drive-thru following the fast
food chain's announcement and another
social media user posted this picture of
a refrigerator stocked with burgers
that reminded us of the hunger for
hamburgers that russians felt back in
1990 when mcdonald's first opened its
first restaurant behind the iron curtain
in moscow's pushkin square our colleague
anthony mason reported extensively from
the soviet union for cbs news then and
he filed this report
the rush of russians into moscow's new
mcdonald's this morning was so great
that even the company's largest
restaurant couldn't really offer fast
food
mcdonald's did offer distractions like
men who balance teapots on their heads
but muscovites are well practiced in the
art of patience
i didn't have to wait long said alosha
only one hour
we line up for lennon's tomb we wait to
see russian heroes said one customer we
can wait to see an american hero too
mcdonald's invested 14 years and 50
million dollars to turn this gray corner
of gorky street into plastic fantastic
americana
they built their own factory with fry
inspectors fun supervisors and
guidelines on bun symmetry and the
soviet waitresses were all sent to
smiling school and given strict
instructions
serving those people one at a time and
we're saying thank you please come back
again for the average russian worker a
big mac takes a big bite about half a
day's pay but no one seemed discouraged
by the cost in time or money after all
if you waited long enough today you got
more than a burger you could see that
teapot man starts spinning a salmon bar
on his head
[Music]
half a day i was just gonna say that's
ridiculous for a big match nice job
anthony mason 14 years 15 million
dollars just to
get that ready and
that's very cool
yes anthony looked great yeah
always still looks great he still does
a great writer still was a great was a
great writer back you're watching
anthony